remember how much fun that just calls to
multiplayer mod was crashing planes and
jacking cars is much more fun with
friends now we'll get to do it all over
again with Just Cause 3 the team that
brought multiplayer to just cause 2 is
giving the pc version of Just Cause 3
the same treatment they've released a
trailer to let us know it's on the way
but haven't said when the mod will be
finished the modders stated we're
incredibly excited to show off the
progress we've made these last few weeks
moving forward you can expect frequent
updates on our progress along with
exciting new developments as they happen
the official Just Cause team at
Avalanche are just as excited for the
new mod they teased multiplayer for the
third game but nothing ever came to
fruition fortunately the modding
community is there to fill in the gaps
we're definitely fans have just cause 3
here at gamespot we even named it one of
the best games of 2015 so whenever the
multiplayer mod drops you can be sure
we'll check it out those wing students
aren't going to fly themselves